well thanks for coming here today folks
i think some of you here or most of you
here last friday we announced a series
of
increased efforts on our part to reduce
if not eliminate the full demonstration
in the safest
most effective and lawful manner
possible
we talked about the surge in contain
since that time we've had 20 arrests and
charges criminal arrests and charges of
individuals who have broken the law
directly or indirectly in regards to
this demonstration
we've issued over 500 tickets to those
individuals who've come here
mostly in conveyances trucks
suvs cars
for an awful conduct
bylaws provincial offenses and criminal
code offenses we have towed vehicles and
we have towed trucks
there has been a significant decrease in
the amount of protesters and vehicles
associated to the protesters over that
time period
the large demonstration that was planned
for this weekend was significantly
smaller than the previous weekend the
previous weekend had three thousand plus
trucks not counting all the other
vehicles
ten to fifteen thousand protesters
that took a 24 7 cycle over friday
saturday and sunday
this weekend the numbers are down around
a thousand trucks
around 5000 protesters and while there
was some activity on saturday there was
almost no activity on friday or on
sunday
that is in direct reaction to our
stepped-up enforcement our surge in
contain and our aggressive intelligence
and investigation operations that have
been taking place over the last four
days and will continue until the end of
this demonstration
what particularly has occurred of a
significant nature
we went after the funding
our efforts combined with the city's
efforts eliminated the gofundme 10
million dollars are no longer accessible
to the demonstrators there are other
funding avenues that we continue to
aggressively go after through
intelligence information coordination
with financial institutions and all
three levels of government we will be
relentless in pursuing the funding that
has enabled this demonstration to
continue to this point
we're going after the fuel
we're going after any vehicle conveyance
including horseback
people carrying jerry cans
we are arresting and seizing and we are
interdicting fuel going into
the demonstrations
last night was a major public order
operation
we tried to end it through negotiation
as we always will do in every aspect
when that failed we went into a public
order operation it included covert
assets as well as investigation and
delegate intelligence assets
seven people were arrested and charged
criminally thousands of liters of
propane and fuel were seized
and we took out an oil tanker and the
entire footprint of the staging area at
coventry park that includes hot tubs and
saunas and anything else that was down
there we've erected fences in that area
and are going to secure that area so
there are no more incursions
over the course of the weekend through
negotiation efforts we peacefully and
fully resolved
the confederation park encampment no
arrests no use of force no injuries no
deaths no riots no encampment in
confederation park
it is gone we have fenced in that area
and reclaimed that territory
expectation setting let me be clear
every time we knock something down there
are attempts for it to pop up in four or
five other locations we're rapidly
deploying our resources whenever we get
a sense of another fuel depot another
staging area or anything else that
enables
the demonstration to continue we send
resources in there we reclaim that
property and we allow ourselves to get
incremental advancements towards the end
of the demonstration
over the last four days in addition to
those operations they will continue on
to be clear
we have been seeking additional
resources provincially and federally and
of course municipally
we've been working very closely with
city manager steve canalakas the mayor's
office and as and our board in order to
seek additional funds there is a formal
request that will be sent to the mayor's
office in the next hour
requesting a significant increase in
police resources civilian resources as
well as requests for significant
increases for bylaw offenses fines and
other enabling orders of government to
allow us to more fully and effectively
and quickly as well as lawfully and
safely end this demonstration
we are turning up the heat in every way
we possibly can within our operations
and enforcement as well as in our
engagement of all three levels of
government
every available ottawa police service
officer has been working for the last
four days let me repeat we have
cancelled days off
there is nobody on a day off getting
rest over the last four days some
officers are on their 14th day straight
of 12 hours in a row during the coldest
snap in in ottawa in the last 10 years
working outside continuously
no officers are on days off everyone has
been working
we are stretched to the limit but we are
100 committed to using everything we
have to end this demonstration we cannot
do it alone that is why i have been
advocating for all three levels of
government to bring whatever they can
bear and bring to bear on the permanent
sustainable lawful safe resolution of
this demonstration
the opp the rcmp at least seven
different municipal police agencies have
embedded their officers within our
incident command structure that has
allowed us to get the relief we need to
move ottawa police officers into the
aggressive mode that you have seen over
the last four days we need more we are
grateful for what they have provided but
we need more
we are advocating for more levels of
government to do more things around
provincial interprovincial and national
strategies to address what is happening
here in the nation's capital
we'll be speaking to council within the
next hour to lay out the resource
requests that we ask the mayor to send
to the provincial solicitor general and
the public safety canada to
significantly increase our resources so
we can significantly escalate our
enforcement and interdictions in and
around the demonstration sites
let me be very clear about one thing as
hard as we have worked and as much as
our people are on the breaking point
the community has worked as hard or
harder and are closer to their breaking
point the stories coming to me are
breaking my heart
i have my own officers who live in and
around those areas and they and their
children have not been able to sleep
they and their children have not been
able to go to school this is crushing
for those residents and their businesses
it has to stop and we are doing
everything we can possibly do to stop it
we need more help we're asking for that
help we're starting to receive that help
but we need more to get this done
last but not least i want to thank the
members of this police service every
single one civilian or sworn front line
or executive we have been 100 full out
on this for the last 10 days straight
and we will not rest until it's done but
we need more help i thank the frontline
men and women who've been out there in
sub 30 degree celsius temperatures for
12 hours straight i thank our
communications operators who have been
receiving hate and threats all day long
24 7. i thank our financial people for
trying to put together the resources to
sustain this i thank everybody and
anybody in our community from counselors
to bias to service providers to the
not-for-profit sector to residents to
school teachers to make this the most
livable thing that we can to get through
it we cannot do it alone we have not
been doing it alone but we are making
real strides and we will continue to
aggressively pursue that in every aspect
going forward thank you very much and
i'd love to take your questions
you know the the protesters said
the protesters laid out their plan well
in advance before coming into ottawa yes
you're turning up the heat now but all
of these plans they said they did
exactly what they said that they were
going to do and
a lot of ottawa residents say this is a
failure of the ottawa police and
ultimately the responsibility lies with
you why is this all happening the second
week into the game thank you very much
for your question um
this is an unprecedented protest
i'm not aware of anybody who has any
experience in managing large-scale
demonstrations whether they be a police
officer or whether they be a public
official who has not already gone on
record stating very clearly this is an
unprecedented protest never seen in
canada and i've heard from colleagues
around the world very rarely have they
ever seen anything like this
so i'll just finish answering my
question answering the question thank
you
so yes there were certainly indications
around which this would be a
demonstration all of our negotiations
with the corps convoy stated that they
would be here on friday and they would
leave on sunday
those negotiations were well in place
days in advance before they came
while there were fringe elements that
said everything from insurrection
through to negotiation
our core negotiations were a
demonstration for three days in the
nation's capital and the return of of
those vehicles and demonstrators to the
parts of canada they came from that is
what we planned for that is what we
executed there was a success around
containing that as it turned into more
than a demonstration we have pivoted and
we pivoted immediately we needed more
resources to deal with a occupation than
with a demonstration i have worked
continuously 18 hour days to get those
resources our partners have started to
bring those resources to beer and as
they come in and as we reduce the size
of the footprint that has been in place
for the last 10 days we redeploy those
resources now we can go on the offensive
that's what we've been doing to great
effect
for clarification though chief are you
saying
that the ottawa police were caught off
guard that the protesters stayed as long
as they stayed
so the ottawa police service have been
able to quell the la the large
demonstration that came in as it's
turned into an occupation we've been
able to pivot and get the resources to
go on offense to remove that demonstrate
occupation while still managing the
elements of the demonstration
we have seen the challenges to our
neighborhoods and our businesses we've
seen the challenges to our officers in
delivering on that we are making
significant progress since we've made
that pivot over the last four days we
need more resources to drive those
successes even further and we might need
more levels of government to play their
role in the overall sustainable end to
this demonstration why did it take a ten
days for the ottawa police to start
confiscating fuel from the protesters
i'm not sure that's an accurate
statement we have been here
at no point thank you very much for your
question we have been introducing the
fuel to the extent that we can we did
not have the resources early in the week
as we get more resources we're able to
do more interdictions that's why we
could do the operation last night to the
scale that we did we need to maintain
and increase these resources so that we
cannot just get on the fuel we can get
to the trucks themselves
please see if there's still uh
demonstrators filling their trucks with
fuel we spoke to protesters at the
coventry site this morning after last
night's raid uh how they still have two
days worth of heating fuel and their
continent will be able to replenish that
what do you believe last night's
operation
accomplished in terms of bringing this
demonstration to the net thank you
excellent question again we've been
trying to say this this is not a simple
demonstration where if you deal with one
set of charges or one particular
location that's the end there is a level
of sustainability financial capability
determined commitment around whatever
the range of causes and i've lost track
of all the range of causes where we get
a success in one area we get an
immediate counter reaction in multiple
other areas it's not like a consecutive
movement end that then deal with that
and then deal with that that has been
the challenge from the beginning that is
why the current structure of this police
service the funding and resources of
this police service is not sufficient to
deal with all of this we need more
resources more help with what we've got
we've made significant impact but we're
going to need a lot more to really get
on top of this situation
that letter is being drafted to the
mayor i'm sure it'll become a very
public document very soon i'm sending of
the mayor he will be sending it to the
solicitor general and then on to public
safety canada we've had meetings as of
this morning with those two levels of
government they know what is coming
their way
they will have it within the next hour
those discussions will continue on no
doubt this evening
we've been making requests since before
they arrived in town we've been
receiving resources as everyone gets an
understanding of the level that we've
needed but we're not going incremental
anymore we're asking for a major push of
resources to come into the next 72 hours
thank you very much folks thank you
questions from four reporters really
that's it
[Music]